[Music]
rebel wilson channels her inner moana
[Music]
the 41 year old actress posted this clip
to tick-tock sunday rocking a red
one-piece swimsuit in the middle of a
body of water with her friends as the
fitting disney track how far i'll go
plays in the background
[Music]
the caption
rebel island yeah it's exciting rebel
shared tons of snaps from rebel island
on instagram too that's the cat star on
a remote island in french polynesia on a
belated birthday trip her b day is
actually in march but i think rebel
island any time of year is a good idea
the australian actress brought some of
her besties along for the trip to
paradise including a few of her pitch
perfect co-stars
[Music]
yep that's britney snow anna kendrick
chrissy fit and shelly regner rocking
80s inspired beachwear alongside a
caption that read in part quote bella's
b-ballin
smash that
and chrissy she shared this shot of the
ladies giving off sultry mermaid vibes
this year i'm concentrating on health
it's a journey
but no i feel good of course this
birthday celebration comes amid rebels
journey of health and wellness
the actress openly declared 2020 the
year of health shortly after she told et
she shed some lbs while filming cats i
lost eight pounds shooting my number in
four days
one because of yeah there's a lot of
physicality when you see the film but
also they heated up the set
very hot to almost 100 fahrenheit
so that we could never cool down
she documented her workouts and shared
her progress with her fans along the way
dropping a whopping 65 pounds
and back in july she opened up about her
initial motivation to live her
healthiest life during an instagram live
it first started when i was like going
through um looking into fertility stuff
and the doctor was like well you have a
much better chance of you are healthier
and so that's kind of what started that
if i'd you know lost some excess weight
that that it would give give me a better
chance for freezing eggs and having the
eggs be a better quality
um so that's what at first it wasn't
even really myself it was more thinking
of a future
mini me really and in august she
encouraged her followers saying
everyone's journey to health is
different quote it's not a race and it's
not a competition it's about respecting
yourself and doing what's best for you
so if you're out there and reading this
today i just wanted to say keep smiling
and keep trying to be active rebel you
inspire me keep it up girl
[Music]
you